ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN [inaudible]
BERMAN BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER HORVATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO.
CERVANTES CHAU [inaudible]
CAN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER CUNNINGHAM.
DALLY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA [inaudible]
FONG FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY
[inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN
[inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN MURATSUCHI
NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RAMOS THREE OF
US ROBERT RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH
[inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER.
WICKS WOOD.
MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN.
THE REVEREND PATTY OSHA
REMINISCED.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
WHAT IS HAPPINESS?
IT IS A UNIVERSAL WONDERMENT.
THE SPIRITUAL TRADITIONS OF
HUMANITY TRY TO TEACH US THAT
ARE REAL HAPPINESS EMERGES
NATURALLY.
WHEN WE ARE ABLE TO TRANSCEND
ARE SELF CENTERED MINDS?
I CAN C<c.cyan> EMERGES WHEN WE</c>
EXPERIENCE IN MINE THAT IS
OTHERS CENTER.
IT IS THE CONTENT MEN OF A
PARENT HOLDING THEIR INFANT
CHILD.
WHERE DOES THE PARENTS LIFE IN?
AND THE CHILD'S LIFE BEGIN.
THE CONTENTMENT EXPERIENCE IS
EQUAL TO THE WHEN THIS THEY FEEL.
WHEN WE FEEL WE ARE TRULY ONE
HAPPINESS AND CONTENTMENT
NATURALLY EMERGE?
TRYING TO USE HUMOR AS YET
PROFOUND POEM CAPTURES THIS
VIVIDLY [inaudible]
HERO.
WHEN THE SHOE FITS THE FOOT IS
FORGOTTEN?
WHEN THE BELT FITS THE BELLY IS
WHEN THE MIND IS RIGHT FOR AND
AGAINST OUR FORGOTTEN? TWENTY
TWO IS TRYING TO TEACH US THAT
TRUE CONTENTMENT IS FOUND IN THE
COMFORT OF BEING.
ONE LIKE THIS SHOE IN THE FOOT
OR THE BELT IN THE BELLY.
WHEN THEY TRULY FITS THE BECOME
ONE AND BOTH ARE FORGOTTEN?
TRYING TO ENDS WITH HIS MOST
IMPORTANT POINT.
WHEN THE MIND IS RIGHT FOR AND
AGAINST ME AGAINST YOU ARE
FORGOTTEN?
THE PERSIAN SPIRITUAL POET RUMI.
DOES IN MASTER AND TRYING TO
WHAT ALL SAY.
BEYOND RIGHT AND WRONG.
BEYOND INSIDE AND OUTSIDE.
BEYOND FOR AND AGAINST THERE IS
A PLACE WHERE WE ARE ONE WITH
ALL HUMANITY.
THAT IS THE PLACE WHERE WE WILL
TRULY MEET.
NUMBER ONE THE NUMBER TWO WHAT
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND OSHITA WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
COOPER -- PLEASE JOIN ME IN
HONORING OUR NATION'S FLAG.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE [inaudible]
STATES. TO POWER WHICH IS.
REYES AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
TUESDAY MAY TWENTY FIRST TWENTY
NINETEEN THE SELLING MEDICINE
AND I AM ON WILL TO RANT ALLEY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FIRST IS
PRESIDING CHIEF COOKIE DOTSON
WILSON AT THE DESK.
READING QUICK KATHLEEN AND WE
WAS RICH TERROR CALDERON MOVES
MISTER FLORA SECONDS.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THE ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BILL BRO. FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEN COOLEY
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE MOVE I'M TWELVE EIGHTY
TWO TWENTY ONE CRISTINA GARCIA
TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO PERMIT THE
BUDGET CONFEREES ASSEMBLY MEMER
STAYING MAYES MCCARTY OBERNOLTE
AND WEBER. TO ADD THEIR VOTES
THE ROLL CALL VOTES TAKEN ON
THIS DAY AS IF PRESIDENT WHILE
THEY ATTEND THE BUDGET
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
MISTER CALDERON YOU
AGAIN RECOGNIZE FOR PROCEDURE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
SIXTY NINETY SEVEN GRAYSON TO
THE NOT TO FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON.
CLICK ON THE
MISTER CALDERON
YOUR RECOGNITION MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I MOVE TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
SIXTY NINE D. THE ONE WAY ONE
DAY WAITING PERIOD FOR AMENDED
BILLS TO ALLOW AUTHORS TO TAKE
UP THE FOLLOWING BILLS ITEM
NUMBER.
THREE AB ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE
COOLEY BY WOULD ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN A. B. SEVEN A SEVEN KALRA
AND ITEM SEVENTEEN AB FOURTEEN
FORTY LEVINE.
MR FLORA THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER WE WITHHOLD UNANIMOUS
CONSENT ASK FOR ROLL CALL VOTE.
THIS CASE MISTER CALDERON MOVES
SECONDED BY MS RUBIO ON THE
RULES SUSPENSION MEMBERS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
MR FLORA AND NO MISTER CALDERON
IS ASKING FOR NINE MISTER FLORA
AND NO.
ON THE PROCEDURAL VOTE.
THIS TAKES FORTY ONE ON THE ROLE
SUSPENSION.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL EYES FORTY THREE
KNOWS ELEVEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING.
TO MOVE TO THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN IS
AB SEVEN OH SEVEN BY MISTER
KALRA COOKERY.
AS SOMETHING ALL SEVEN OH SEVEN
BY SONY MEMBER CALLED RAN OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
CONTRACTS MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
A. B. SEVEN OH SEVEN IS A
DISTRICT BILL WITH BIPARTISAN
AND UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN POLICY
COMMITTEE.
RECENT AMENDMENTS TO MOVE
OPPOSITION WITH OUR COMMITMENT
TO CONTINUE WORKING ON LANGUAGE
IN THE SENATE.
AS AMENDED AB SEVEN OH SEVEN
ROLE CHRIS TO CAP ON WORK DONE
BY THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT. TO FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS WITH LIMITED EXCEPTIONS
IN THE CASE OF CHANNEL
MAINTENANCE ENVIRONMENTAL
PRESERVATION HABITAT MANAGEMENT
OR EMERGENCY WORK ANY PROJECTS
ASKED ME TO COST OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO GO THROUGH A
FORMAL BIDDING PROCESS.
THIS DRESS WAS NOT BEEN INCREASE
SINCE ITS CREATION SINCE THAT
TIME INFLATION IS ABOUT OF THE
PURCHASING POWER THE THRESHOLD.
TO THE EXTENT THAT EVEN SIMPLE
PROJECTS SUCH AS ERECTING A
FENCE WE'RE INSTALLING A
WAREHOUSE GARAGE DOOR REQUIRES A
FORMAL BIDDING PROCESS WHICH CAN
COST MORE THAN THE ACTUAL
PROJECT.
AB SEVEN OH SEVEN ON A NIPPLE
PARITY TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT AND OTHER PUBLIC
AGENCIES DELIVER MORE COST
EFFECTIVE AND TIMELY PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS BELOW FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS KALRA SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
VOTERS ARE THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE THOSE.
THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FIFTY
TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WHATEVER BACK ON THE TOP
FILE THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE AB ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
TWENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
HEALTH.
DOCTOR WOULD YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE
REGARDINGTHE CERTIFICATION OF
ANIMAL CONTROL OFFICERS ANIMAL
CONTROL OFFICER ACTIVITIES ARE
FUNCTIONAL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PERFORMED TO ENSURE THE
PROTECTION.
THE HEALTH AND WELFARE OF
ANIMALS WITHIN THE COMMUNITY AS
WELL AS THAT OF HUMANS LIVING
WITH THEM AND AROUND THEM.
IN RECENT YEARS HAVE BEEN
INCIDENTS REPORTED TO THE
CALIFORNIA AMERICA ANIMAL
WELFARE ASSOCIATION TO
DEMONSTRATE THE BENEFIT THAT
PROFESSIONALIZATION OF THIS
WORKFORCE COULD PROVIDE.
A BE ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE
ESTABLISHES A PRINT FRAMEWORK
THROUGH WHICH ANIMAL CONTROL
OFFICERS MAYBE SEE STATE
RECOGNIZED CERTIFICATION IF THEY
SO CHOOSE SO FOSTER GREATER
UNIFORMITY AND PROFESSIONALISM.
IN THIS IMPORTANT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ACTIVITY ALSO HELP
LOAD LOCAL AGENCIES IDENTIFY
SELECT AND TRAIN QUALIFIED
PUBLIC OFFICERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK ADEQUATE SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE
AYE AYES FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES WE'RE GOING TO
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS.
FOR FIVE AND SIX AS WELL AS FILE
ITEMS EIGHT NINE AND TEN MEMBERS
WERE FILE ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
ELEVEN AB. FIFTY SIX CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY SIX BY
SOMETHING MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO
ELECTRICITY.
MR GARCIA YOU MAIL MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES GOOD
MORNING.
RICE TODAY TO PRESENT DAY BE.
FIFTY SIX THE BILL THAT WOULD
ADDRESS THE FACT THAT NO ONE I
THINK DISAGREES WITH.
THE NATURE OF ENERGY PROCUREMENT
IN CALIFORNIA AND HOW IT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGING.
I'D LIKE TO START OFF BY.
TALKING A BIT ABOUT THE BILL AS
IT RELATES TO WHAT THE BILL DOES
NOT DO.
GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT ARE
PRESENTED THEMSELVES -- VIA THE
OPPOSITION -- SHARING WITH MANY
OF YOU.
THE BILL DOES NOT CHANGE ANY OF
THE P. UC'S EXISTING AUTHORITY
TO MANDY PROCUREMENT.
THIS BILL DOES NOT PASS THE P.
YOU SEE WILL STILL BE ABLE TO
MANDATE PROCUREMENT OF VARIOUS
ENERGY RESOURCES.
THROUGH THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES.
THAT'S GOT TO BE MADE VERY VERY
CLEAR.
THE BILL WILL DO NOTHING. TO
INTERFERE AT ALL WITH THE
PROCUREMENT.
CHOICES OF INDIVIDUAL LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES.
ALL THE L. S. EASE WILL STILL BE
ABLE TO DO PROCUREMENT.
AS THEY CURRENTLY DO AND IF THEY
MEET THEIR OBLIGATIONS UNDER THE
LAW THERE WOULD BE NO NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL PROCUREMENT TO BE
MANDATED BY THE P. YOU SEE.
THIS BILL WILL NOT REQUIRE
ANYONE. TO PAY FOR POWER THAT
WAS NOT PURCHASED ON THEIR
BEHALF.
AS IS CURRENT PRACTICE ANY
PROCUREMENT MANDATED BY THE P.
YOU SEE WHAT HAVE ITS COST
ASSIGNED. TO THE CUSTOMERS ON
WHOSE BEHALF THAT PROCUREMENT
WAS DONE FOR IN FACT.
I CHALLENGE ANYONE. TWO POINT TO
US WHERE IN THE BILL.
IT SAYS THOSE THREE THINGS.
AB FIFTY SIX SIMPLY GIVES THE P.
YOU SEE THE ABILITY. TO REQUIRE
THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE
ENERGY AN ADVANCE TRANSPORTATION.
FINANCING AUTHORITY TO PROCURE
BACKSTOP POWER AS GAPS ARE
IDENTIFIED. TO BE VERY CLEAR
AGAIN.
THIS BILL DOES NOT PASS.
THE PROCUREMENT WILL STILL
HAPPEN AT THIS CURRENTLY DONE
THROUGH THE I USE.
AND WILL BE FORCED TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO ENSURE THAT PROCUREMENT
CONTINUES WHEN TWO OR THREE
LARGE I'LL USE.
EITHER CAN'T OR DON'T WANT TO
CONTINUE THAT ROLE.
IT I KNOW MANY IF NOT MOST OF
YOU HAVE HEARD FROM OUR CCA
PARTNERS.
FROM YOUR DISTRICT OR STATE WIDE
ASSOCIATIONS ALLEGING THAT THIS
BILL WILL DISRUPT THEIR ABILITY.
WE HAVE BEEN MEETING WITH CC
EIGHT STAKEHOLDER SINCE FEBRUARY.
AND ARE HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN
FIGURE OUT THE DETAILS. TO
ENSURE THAT DOES NOT HAPPEN.
LET ME SAY UNEQUIVOCALLY.
THAT IS THE POSITION THAT WE'VE
TAKEN.
AND IF THE BILL DOES ANYTHING
OTHER THAN WHAT WE'VE SAID IT
DOES.
WE WILL MAKE SURE.
OUT TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES OR
YOU WON'T SEE THIS BILL COME
BACK. FOR CONCURRENCE.
IF THAT NEEDS TO BE FURTHER
CLARIFIED.
I AM HAPPY AND I WELCOME.
MANY OF YOU WHO ARE INTERESTED
IN THIS SUBJECT. TO HELP US
BRING THIS TOGETHER.
THIS IS THE RIGHT MOVE FOR
CALIFORNIA COLLEAGUES. FOR
GREATER RELIABILITY [inaudible]
SUSTAINABILITY. TO REACHING OUR
AGGRESSIVE CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I WANT TO JUST CLOSE BY
THINKING MY COLLEAGUE FROM
DELMAR FOR SHEPHERDING THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
IN MY ABSENCE. FOR A FEW OF OUR
SESSIONS IN COMMITTEES I WOULD
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL
TAKE THIS GARCIA DOCTOR QUIRK.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
SO I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIFTY SIX WE HAVE ALREADY HAD
SITUATIONS [inaudible]
BECAUSE THAT.
HE INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR
HAS SEEN THAT WE DO NOT HAVE
ENOUGH ENERGY. TO KEEP
ELECTRICITY ON WHAT THEY DO THEN.
IS TO CONTRACT ON A SHORT TERM
BASIS WHAT ARE CALLED.
RELIABILITY MUST RUN RMR
CONTRACTS.
THESE ARE EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE.
WHAT THIS PROCUREMENT WOULD DO
WOULD BE TO SAY IF THE I. S. O.
SEES A PROBLEM ON THE GRID?
THAT YOU CAN ENTER INTO A LONG
TERM CONTRACT WHICH IS MUCH
CHEAPER THAN WHAT WE'RE DOING
NOW.
RELIABILITY MUST RYAN IS
EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE IT DOESN'T
ALLOW IN FACT FOR EVEN THESE
PLANTS TO PLAN AHEAD.
IN ANY WAY IT DOESN'T ALLOW FOR
MAINTENANCE AT CETERA.
THIS IS A FAR BETTER WAY OF
LOOKING AT BACK UP.
THEN USE DEBATE.
THERE WE ARE IN A TRANSITION.
FROM PREDOMINANTLY THE
INDEPENDENT.
OUR SHE'S ME FROM THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES TO THE COMMUNITY
CHOICE AGGREGATORS.
SOMETIMES THINGS FALL THROUGH
THE CRACKS.
RIGHT NOW THOSE CRACKS ARE BEING
MAINTAINED THROUGH SHORT TERM
VERY EXPENSIVE CONTRACTS.
THIS WOULD ALLOW WHEN THE I SO
SEES A CRACK HAVE A LONGER TERM
CRANCH CONTRACT.
UNTIL THIS CAN BE SOLVED BY THE
ENERGY PURCHASERS PREDOMINANTLY
THE THE COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATORS.
I URGE YOU TO BRING THIS BILL ON
TO THE SENATE.
ARM.
AND THE STE THE COMMUNITY TRIES
AGGREGATORS OF AS THE THE AUTHOR
HAS SAID.
WE'LL BE ABLE TO GO OVER THIS
LANGUAGE AND MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
DOING EXACTLY WHAT I SAY.
THAT IS WHEN THERE IS A CRACK IT
GETS FILLED AND IT GETS FILLED
IN A WAY WHICH IS CHEAPER THAN
WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW.
SO PLEASE HELP THIS BILL GET ON
TO THE SENATE.
WHERE THE COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATORS CAN MAKE SURE THAT
THE BILL DOES WHAT I'VE JUST
SAID AND WHAT THE AUTHOR SAYS IT
JUST SAID THANK YOU?
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK MISTER
MERCY G. YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I RISE A
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
THIS BILL CAME BEFORE THE
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMISSION --
COMMITTEE.
WHERE THE AUTHOR WHO WE ALL KNOW?
IT -- LIKES TO TAKE ON BIG BILLS
AND PUTS IN THE WORK NECESSARY.
TO TO A PRODUCE GOOD POLICY.
NONE THE LESS YOU KNOW I'M
CONCERNED THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT [inaudible]
PROCUREMENT MANDATES.
THERE IS.
SIGNIFICANT AMBIGUITY THAT HAS
NOT BEEN CLEARED UP SINCE THE
UTILITIES COMMITTEE HEARING.
AND I'M LOOKING AT THE
OPPOSITION LIST HERE.
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE LIKE ME A LOT
OF TIMES IF YOU'RE DEALING WITH
A COMPLICATED SUBJECT.
YOU LOOK AT WHO'S SUPPORTING IT
WHO'S OPPOSING IN.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS A
UPDATED LESS THIS IS ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT I HAVE.
BUT THIS IS BEING SUPPORTED BY
THE BIOMASS ALLIANCE AS BEING
OPPOSED BY SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON.
BY ALL OF THE CCA'S BY THE CLEAN
POWER ALLIANCE OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN PARTICULAR.
THE LARGEST CCA INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA.
AS WELL AS SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP I THINK THERE'S
REASON FOR CONCERN HERE.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT.
MEMBERS WERE AWARE OF THAT THIS
IS A AND BUSINESS BILL WITH A
LOT OF ON UNANSWERED QUESTIONS.
I THINK.
PROCUREMENT SHOULD BE LEFT TO
THE GROWING MOVEMENT OF OUR
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATORS WHO
ARE EXPECTED PROVIDE UP 280% OF
OUR ENERGY.
IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI MISS
BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY SIX
THIS IS FOR CLARIFICATION THIS
IS NOT A PROCUREMENT MANDATE --
THIS IS CENTRALIZED PROCUREMENT
THAT IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
UTILITIES SYSTEM MOVING FORWARD
AS THE SYSTEM MOVES FORWARD AS
IT EVOLVES WE ARE GOING TO NEED
CENTRALIZED PROCUREMENT IN THE
EVENT THAT OTHER.
THINGS LIKE P. GENIES SITUATIONS
HAPPEN AGAIN WHERE PROCUREMENT
MAY BECOME AN ISSUE WE DO NEED A
DEFAULT AB CENTRALIZED
PROCUREMENT OF LAST RESORT.
THIS BILL STARTS THAT ROCESS
AND I RECOMMEND ALSO PEOPLE LOOK
AT THAT TURN IS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL WHICH IS IMPORTANT
FACTOR.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS BURKE.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM.
MR GARCIA YOU MAY CLOSE.
JUST WANT.
TO STAND CORRECTED TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM REALLY DEL REY
NOT THEY'LL MARK -- AND I
APPRECIATE.
MY COLLEAGUES -- FROM TORRANCE --
RAISING.
THOSE CONCERNS -- THAT HE HAS I
I TRULY BELIEVE THATWE CAN
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS -- MOVING
FORWARD THE QUESTION WILL THEN
BECOME.
IF OUR GOOD PARTNERS -- FROM OUR
CCA'S.
WILL HELP US WITH THE SEMANTICS
THE LANGUAGE YOU KNOW -- CHOICE
OF WORDS THAT NEED TO BE MAYBE
PUT IN THIS BILL TO ENSURE THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND AS WE UNDERSTAND.
AS A BILL AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN
OF WHAT IT DOES VERSES WHAT IT
DOESN'T DO.
AND SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
THIS CONVERSATION CONTINUING
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I WILL
COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU MR GARCIA.
THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS IS OUT OF OUT.
MR GARCIA MOVES A CALL
.
I WAS VERY FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTEEN AB TWO THIRTY SIX BY MR
GARCIA.
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
THIRTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO SPECIAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS.
MR GARCIA MAIL THANK YOU WAS
SPEAKER AS I CATCH MY BREATH
HERE I PRESENT TO YOU.
AB TWO THREE SIX THE BILL THAT
WOULD STRENGTHEN THE CRITICAL
WORK OF FAMILY APARTMENTS
ENTERED.
BY INSURING THAT FAMILIES OF
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES HAVE
ACCESS TO TO THE NEED TO HELP
THEIR CHILDREN THRIVE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FREE AYE VOTE.
AMOS ARSIA.
MISTER FRAZIER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REALLY APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
AS WE KNOW THERE'S CRITICAL
SERVICES THAT ARE NEEDED FOR THE
SPECIAL NEEDS COMMUNITY.
I'LL JUST USE AN EXAMPLE OF OF
WHAT'S GOING ON IN REAL LIFE.
THE REGIONAL CENTERS GENERALLY
DON'T POST A A LIST OF OUR A
MENU OF SERVICES FOR THE
FAMILIES IN THIS APPLICATION FOR
THE FAMILIES.
IS ESSENTIAL TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY GET EVERY SERVICE THAT THEY
DESERVE.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE
ADVOCATES.
A PROPOSAL FOR THE PROGRESS OF
THEIR CHILDREN I HIGHLY
RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTE AND I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THE ON MISTER FRASIER'S COMMENT.
MR GARCIA YOU MAY CLOSE YOU WISH
WITH THAT CLUB OF THE ROLE.
IT IS OUT OF OUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
WELL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE.
AS SIXTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WHERE PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER?
FIFTEEN WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SIXTEEN AB.
TEN EIGHTY BY MISS GONZALES
CORKERY.
AT SOME LEVEL TEN EIGHTY BY
SEVEN MEMBER GETS ALL IS
ANOTHER'S ACTUALLY A SOLID WASTE.
IT'S GONZALEZ THANK YOU OUR
ENVIRONMENT IS BEING OVERRUN BY
LATER AND YOU CAN SEE IT
EVERYWHERE FROM OUR BEACHES TO
OUR PARKS ARE INLAND WATERWAYS.
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE BEING
FLOODED BY WASTE ARE SIMPLY NOT
ABLE TO KEEP UP THE AMOUNT OF
WASTE WE GENERATE TO FIND
OVERSEAS MARKETS TO SHIP OUR SO
CALLED RECYCLABLES. TO LIKE THEY
USED.
TO COMMUNITIES PARTICULARLY
THOSE OF COLOR AND LOW INCOME
LIKE MINE WHO LIVE ALONG THE
COAST SEE THIS THE MOST.
WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
HER PLASTIC WASTE AND IT'S TIME
THAT WE TAKE A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH AS A STATE TO DEALING
WITH IT.
AB TEN EIGHTY WOULD ENSURE
CALIFORNIA'S ON THE FOREFRONT OF
REDUCING POLLUTION FROM SINGLE
USE PACKAGING AND PRODUCTS BY
ESTABLISHING A COMPREHENSIVE
GOAL OF REDUCING OUR WASTE.
FROM THESE ITEMS 275% BY TWENTY
THIRTY THREE SOURCE REDUCTION
AND RECYCLING SPECIFICALLY THOSE
MADE OF PLASTIC.
THE BILL WOULD DIRECT CAL
RECYCLED TO DEVELOP REGULATIONS
ON SINGLE USE PACKAGING AND THE
TOP TEN PRIORITY SINGLE USE
PLASTIC ITEMS BASED ON LETTER
SURVEYS REQUIRE MANUFACTURERS TO
SOURCE REDUCE THESE ITEMS TO
EXTENT FEASIBLE AND ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE FULLY RECYCLABLE OUR
COMPOSTABLE.
THE PACKAGING A PRIORITY SINGLE
USE ITEMS THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
MANUFACTURERS TO MEET INTERIM
RECYCLING GOALS OF 20% BY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR WHICH WE KNOW SOME
INDUSTRIES CAN ALREADY MEET.
AND FORTY CENT PERCENT BY.
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT COLLEAGUES
THIS EXACT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
PASSED THE SENATE YESTERDAY WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IT'S
IMPORTANT AS WE MOVE THESE BILLS
FOR IT AND THERE WILL BE
CONTINUED DISCUSSION.
ABOUT HOW WE MAKE THESE BETTER
HOW WE CREATE SOME SORT OF OFF
RAMPS HOW WE DO A SCOPING PLAN
BUT AT SOME POINT THAT WE HAVE
OUR VOICE HEARD AS WELL AND WE
DON'T JUST ACCEPT.
AS SENATE BILL MOVING INTO OUR
HOUSE AND MOVING THIS TYPE OF
BIG PROGRAM FOR IT SO TODAY I
ASK THAT YOU HELP ME AND MOVING
IT FORWARDAND I'M RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
FAMOUS BECAUSE ALL START QUIRK
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
YES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TEN EIGHTY WE REALLY DO NEED TO
HAVE.
THIS AUTHOR RINGING A BELL
FORWARD.
SHE KNOWS HOW TO NEGOTIATE.
I HAVE TALKED ABOUT MY MY
CONCERNABOUT.
DO WE REALLY KNOW WHAT THE RIGHT
NUMBER IS AND SHE IS TOLD ME
SHE'S WILLING TO WORK ON THAT
WE'LL SEE IF WE CAN COME UP WITH
A SOLUTION THERE.
BUT WE DON'T KNOW AT THE PRESENT
TIME WHETHER 75% THE RIGHT
NUMBER OR EIGHTY OR TWENTY AND I
BELIEVE THIS AUTHOR WILL FIND A
WAY SO THAT WE CAN GET TO THE
RIGHT NUMBER WHETHER IT'S HIGHER
OR LOWER.
SO AGAIN I STRONGLY SUPPORT --
FOUGHT.
AB TEN EIGHTY AND KEEPING THE
ASSEMBLY AND THIS AUTHOR IN THE
GAME TO NEGOTIATE AS WE GO
FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK.
MISTER CALDERON [inaudible]
YOUR RECOGNIZE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER SPEAKER IS A MEMBERS
TODAY I'M PROUD TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE ACT
RIGHT NOW TO REDUCE OUR RELIANCE
ON SINGLE USE PLASTIC CYNOSURE
THAT PLASTICS.
WE ARE USING ARE RECYCLABLE AND
COMPOSTABLE THIS BILL SAYS LOFTY
GOALS FOR CALIFORNIANS.
BUT OUR INDUSTRIES AND CITIZENS
ARE FULLY CAPABLE OF RISING TO
MEET THEM.
PLASTIC ITEMS CAN BE FOUND
LETTER THREE OUT THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
BEAUTIFUL COASTLINE THE BE SEEN
OUR LANDFILLS AND OUR WATER WAYS.
BUT PLASTIC WASTE THAT GETS
DISCARDED INTO THE ENVIRONMENT
DAMAGES ECOSYSTEMS AND MARINE
LIFE IT CONTAINS A CONTAMINATES
OUR FOOD SUPPLY AND CAN LEAD TO
CHEMICAL LEACHING.
EXPOSURE TO THESE PLASTICS ARE
AND ASSOCIATED TOXINS HAS BEEN
LINKED TO CANCER BIRTH DEFECTS
IMPAIRED IMMUNITY ENDOCRINE
DISRUPTION AND OTHER SERIOUS
HEALTH PROBLEMS.
ADDITIONALLY PLASTICS NEGATIVELY
IMPACTS MARINE ECOSYSTEMS AND
WILDLIFE COUNTLESS SEA BIRDS
TURTLES MARINE MAMMALS WHALES
AND DOLPHINS DIE FROM INGESTION
AND DIDN'T OR ENTANGLEMENT.
I MEAN HOW MANY TIMES WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT TWITTER TURN ON THE NEWS
TO FIND A DEAD WHALE HAS ROLLED
UP ON A BEACH WITH A STOMACH
FULL OF THIRTY POUNDS OF PLASTIC.
RESEARCHERS ANTICIPATE A 40%
INCREASE IN PLASTIC PRODUCTION
OVER THE NEXT DECADE AT WHICH
POINT PLASTIC PRODUCTION WILL
ACCOUNT 420% OF GLOBAL FOSSIL
FUEL CONSUMPTION.
A LOT OF TIMES WE HEAR THIS
ARGUMENT THAT WERE CALIFORNIA SO
DOES MAKE SENSE WE DO THIS
BECAUSE WE REPRESENT SUCH A
SMALL PIECE OF THE PROBLEM WITH
THAT'S A RIDICULOUS ARGUMENT
BECAUSE WE ARE A LEADER WE ARE A
TREND SETTER.
WHAT WE DO MATTERS NOT JUST ON A
NATIONAL LEVEL BUT ON THE
INTERNATIONAL LEVEL SO THE
DECISIONS WE MAKE THE TONES WE
SAT?
IS WHAT IS IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF
CHANGING THE CONVERSATION AROUND
ITEMS LIKE SINGLE USE PLASTICS
THAT ARE IN OUR FOOD SUPPLY AND
THAT ARE DAMAGING OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND HAVING A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT.
NOT MAYBE NECESSARILY THOROUGHLY
UNDERSTOOD HOW SIGNIFICANT OF AN
IMPACT THAT THEY'RE HAVING ON US
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE CONSUMING
THEM IN OUR FOOD THIS BILL SETS
GOALS THAT WILL PROTECT HUMAN
AND WILDLIFE HEALTH.
REDUCE CLEANUP COST IN OUR
RELIANCE ON FOSSIL FUELS RESTORE
ECOSYSTEMS AND REVITALIZE
RESOURCE DEPENDENT COMMUNITIES.
LET'S CONTINUE THE TO POSITION
CALIFORNIA IS A GLOBAL LEADER IN
PRESERVING AND PROTECTING OUR
ENVIRONMENT A STRONG WE WERE
JUST AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THEY MUST CALDERON MS FRIEDMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RIDE TODAY RIGHT SAY IT'S A
VERY PROUD CO AUTHOR.
OF AB.
TEN EIGHTY MEMBERS WE KNOW THAT
WE HAVE A CRISIS WHEN IT COMES
TO RECYCLING AND TO PLASTIC
WASTE AROUND THE GLOBE.
IN FACT IF YOU ASK ALMOST ANY
SCHOOL CHILD THEY WILL TELL YOU.
HOW MUCH OF A CRISIS THAT WE
HAVE BUT WE HAVE NOT BEEN ACTING
AS THOUGH WE HAVE A CRISIS?
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT WE DON'T HAVE
WE DO NOT HAVE A CRISIS OF
TECHNOLOGY.
WE HAVE TECHNOLOGY THAT IS
PERFECTLY CAPABLE OF
MANUFACTURING RECYCLABLE ITEMS.
THAT ARE EASY TO RECYCLE.
AND A RECYCLING THOSE ITEMS WHAT
WE HAVE HAD IS A CRISIS A
POLITICAL WILL TO REQUIRE THAT
OF MANUFACTURERS.
WE KNOW THAT CHINA AND THE OTHER
THREAD THIRD WORLD COUNTRIES
THAT HAVE BEEN WE HAVE BEEN
DUMPING OUR GARBAGE ON FOR YEARS
NO LONGER ARE GOING TO TAKE OUR
GARBAGE.
IN FACT JUST THIS MORNING I READ
THAT MALAYSIA IS ACTUALLY
SENDING PLASTIC WASTE BACK TO
UNITED STATES.
THEY ARE PUTTING THEM ON BOATS.
ON FREIGHTERS POWERED BY DIRTY
DIESEL OF COURSE AND SENDING
THEM RIGHT BACK TO US.
WE HAVE A LOUD SHIPPERS AND
MANUFACTURERS TO LITERALLY
DUMPED GARBAGE AND PLASTIC INTO
OUR COMMUNITY AND WHO DO WE
EXPECT TO BEAR THE COST OF THAT
WASTE.
OUR RESIDENTS.
WHO ARE GOING TO SEE VERY LARGE
INCREASES IN THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT THEY PAY? FOR THEIR TRASH.
AND THEN THEY'RE GOING TO BLAME
US FOR THAT.
WE HAVE ALLOWED MANUFACTURERS.
OFF THE HOOK FOR FAR TOO LONG
THEY SHOULD TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE PRODUCTS THAT THEY
CREATE.
THEY SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT
WHATEVER PRODUCTS THEY PUT OUT
ARE NOT JUST TECHNOLOGICALLY
RECYCLABLE IN A LABORATORY BUT
PRACTICALLY IN EASILY RECYCLED
OUT IN THE FIELD.
WE HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY TO DO
THAT WE'VE ONLY HAD A POLITICAL
LACK OF WILL.
WELL OUR CHILDREN ARE DEMANDING
MORE FROM US ARE DYING OCEANS
ARE PAYING TESTAMENT TO OUR
FAILURE.
I'M CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD THE
WORLD IN CORRECTING THAT CHANGE.
AND SETTING THE STANDARD THAT
OTHER NATIONS AND OTHER STATES
WILL FOLLOW I URGE AN AYE VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU.
MR BLOOM YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I MEMBERS I
REALLY JUST WANT TO CHIME IN
HERE AND I'M ALSO PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF OF THIS BILL -- AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON PLASTICS ISSUES --
AND SINCE MY TIME IN THE SANTA
MONICA CITY COUNCIL WHERE WE
STARTED WITH PLASTIC BAGS AND
THAT WAS A LONG STRUGGLE BUT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ONE BECAUSE
WHEN PLASTIC HITS THE OCEAN --
IT NEVER GOES AWAY YOU KNOW
UNLESS WE ACTUALLY GO THERE AND
TAKE IT OUT IT NEVER GOES AWAY.
MORE TO THE POINT THAT THE
MEMBER FROM WHITTIER WAS MAKING
CALIFORNIA IS.
A NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL
TREND SETTER HOW DO WE KNOW THAT
MY PLASTIC MICROBEADS
LEGISLATION OF A COUPLE YEARS
AGO IT PASSED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WITHIN A YEAR CONGRESS
REALIZING THAT A SINGLE STANDARD
FOR THE COUNTRY -- WAS IMPORTANT
AND SEEING HOW MUCH MARKET SHARE
CALIFORNIA HAD -- YEAH IT
IMITATED CALIFORNIAN IMPLEMENTED
A NATIONAL BAN ON PLASTICS WE DO
HAVE AN IMPACT THIS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION AND I URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY WAS BLOOM DOCTOR EGGMAN
YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEMBERS.
I CAN TALK TRASH ALL DAY LONG.
BUT FOR YOUR BENEFIT I WON'T I
WILL SIMPLY SAY WE ALL KNOW WE
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THIS.
WHEN WE SAID IT COULDN'T BE DONE
THAT WE COULDN'T GET RID OF --
PLASTIC BAGS WE DID THAT AND
WE'D VISIBLY EVERYBODY CAN SEE
VISIBLY IN YOUR COMMUNITIES YOU
DON'T SEE THE AMOUNT OF BAGS
FLYING AROUND AND AND CLOGGING
UP TRAINS LIKE YOU USED TO WE
HAVE A PROBLEM.
ALL OF OUR CHILDREN NO I JUST
SPENT THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS
WATCHING KIDS PROJECTS AS ARE
PREPARING TO GRADUATE OUT HALF
OF THEM -- ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS
WERE ABOUT WASTE PLASTIC AND
WHAT IT'S DOING TO OUR
ENVIRONMENT WE NEED TO SET A
PLAN WE WERE USING LESS WHAT
WE'RE USING IS RECYCLABLE AND WE
ALL HAVE TO DO THIS TOGETHER.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I VOTED
TO KEEP THIS MOVING WE'RE IN
THIS CONVERSATION LET'S KEEP
HAVING THE CONVERSATION. EIGHT
OUT BRAVE MEN HELLO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS -- I ALSO A
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
I'LL BUT I ALSO WANT TO PROVIDE
A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT WITH
RESPECT TO A WHAT INDUSTRY IN
THIS BODY HAS BEEN DOING -- ON
THESE ISSUES IN FACT A LAST YEAR
I AUTHORED ASSEMBLY BILL --
TWENTY NINE TWENTY ONE A JOINT
AUTHORED BY THE OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SACRAMENTO -- AND THIS
WOULD HAVE ALLOWED INDUSTRY TO
ASSESS A FEE ON THEMSELVES TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE OF THE IMPACT
ON THE ENVIRONMENT SO I JUST
WANT TO URGE CAUTION WHEN.
THINKING ABOUT THE CONVERSATION
ON THE ROLE THAT INDUSTRY HAS
PLAYED BECAUSE THEY ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT THEY NEED TO BE
PART OF THE SOLUTION.
HAVING SAID THAT I ALSO THINK IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY ON LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT.
WHEN I TAKE A LOOK AT THIS BILL
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SOME
OF THE LANGUAGE AND THAT OF THE
AUTHORITY OF CAL RECYCLE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE ALSO TAKE A
LOOK AT IMPLEMENTATION?
AND THE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
THAT WE HAVE AS WELL SO AGAIN
URGE AN AYE VOTE BUT WANT TO
THANK INDUSTRY FOR TRYING TO
CONTINUALLY WORK.
AT THE SAME TIME ADDRESSING
THESE ISSUES.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION MISS GONZALES.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
YOU KNOW THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IF YOU'RE AN
ENVIRONMENTALIST YOU CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT IF YOU'VE GOT CHILDREN AND
YOU SEE THE WASTER YOU GOT FIFTH
GRADERS TRUST ME THEY COME HOME
WITH ALL THE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE GARBAGE PATCH IN THE OCEAN.
BUT THIS IS ALSO A HUGE COST TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND IT'S GOING
TO GROW IN THEN IT WILL BE A
HUGE COST TO TAXPAYERS IT'S
SOMETHING WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
AND IN FACT I THINK WE'RE
DEALING WITH IT AND RESPONSIBLE
WAY THAT WILL ACTUALLY CREATE
JOBS HERE IN.
CALIFORNIA THAT'LL INSURE THAT
WE BECOME A STATE THAT IS A
LEADER ALONG WITH EUROPEAN
NATIONS ON THIS ISSUE IN THAT WE
CREATE A WIN WIN IN ACTUALLY
PRODUCE THINGS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE SUSTAINABLE RECYCLABLE
COMPOSABLE IN THE RECYCLE THEM
RIGHT HERE.
NOT RELYING ON FOREIGN COUNTRIES
TO TAKE OUR TRASH SO I I HOPE
WILL MOVE THIS FOR AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
NAME IS GONZALEZ WITH THAT CAR
CLUB ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF OUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALUD BUT ICE FORTY
TWO KNOWS.
FOURTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE BACK
TO MR GARCIA.
SO MR GARCIA MAY TAKE UP FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
FOURTEEN AB THREE EIGHTY SIX
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
EIGHTY SIX BY SOMETHING MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA AND OTHERS AND I
TELLING TO ENERGY EFFICIENCY.
MR GARCIA MAKE AT ALL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES A.
B. THREE EIGHTY SIX WILL REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT.
TO DEVELOP AND ADMINISTER THE
AGRICULTURE WORKING POOR ENERGY
EFFICIENT HOUSING PROGRAM IN
ORDER TO IMPROVE.
ENERGY FOR EFFICIENCY IN FARM
WORKER ON HOUSING THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
HEY MISTER CSE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ADAM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE OF
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER TIDE ABOUT EYES.
FIFTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MISTER CALDERON FOR WHAT PURPOSE
THE RISER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THAT AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE FILE ITEM
FOR A. B. TEN NINETY ONE JONES
SAWYER TO THE NECK TO FILE.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE ALSO AT THE
REQUEST OF THE OTHER PLEASE MOVE
FILE ITEM NUMBER. FIFTEEN AB
FIVE FIVE FIVE TO THE INACTIVE
FILES WILL.
PURPLE AGAIN NO
.
MEMBERS IN FILE ORDER FILE ITEM.
SEVENTEEN IS MITCHELL OF BEANS
AB FOURTEEN FORTY COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FORTY BY
SELLING MEMBER LEVINE AND
ACTUALLY THE OIL AND GAS.
MR LEVINE YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
THAT TOP LINE FOR EVERYONE THIS
MORNING IS.
ALL OPPOSITION HAS BEEN REMOVED
FROM THIS BILL.
I JUST WANT TO START RIGHT THERE.
WE HAVE MOVED THEM TO NEUTRAL.
AND IT OF COURSE WE HAVE SUPPORT.
AND WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
TAKES REGULATIONS FROZEN IN TIME
DEVELOPED DURING THE GREAT
DEPRESSION IN THE NINETEEN
THIRTIES.
ON HOW DAGR REGULATES OIL
PERMITS ALL IT DOES IS SAY THAT
NOW DAGR CAN CONSIDER PUBLIC
HEALTH JUST LIKE OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENTS THAT GOVERNED
NATURAL RESOURCES.
THIS SIZE THIS IS SOMETHING WE
NEED TO DO TO PRIORITIZE OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND PUBLIC HEALTH
AND MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ON A BILL WHERE ALL OPPOSITION
HAS BEEN REMOVED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR REITERATING THAT
MISSILE LIVING.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
ON THIS BILL WITHOUT OPPOSITION.
CLERK WILL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE [inaudible]
ALL OF ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
ABOUT
.
ALL MEMBERS OF HER DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLIED ABOUT
EYES FORTY THREE KNOWS.
FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
MISTER CALDERON FOR WHAT PURPOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE FILE ITEM EIGHT A. B. SIX
TWO SIX TWO THE INACTIVE FILE.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
AND FILE ITEMS EIGHTEEN AND
NINETEEN FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN BY MISTER
GARCIA CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY SOMETHING MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO THE SALTON SEA.
MR GARCIA.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN COLLEAGUES
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN HAS TWO OBJECTIVES ONE IS
TO ESTABLISH.
THE OFFICE OF THE SALTON SEA.
AND THE OTHER IS TO HAVE THE
SECRETARY OF NATURAL RESOURCES
ESTABLISH THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE. FOR THE WORK THAT
WILL BE CARRIED OUT AT THE
SALTON SEA.
STATE A CALIFORNIA IS ON THE
HOOK FOR LIABILITY AS RELEASED A
MITIGATION.
OF THE AIR QUALITY PROBLEMS AS A
RESULT OF WATER TRANSFERS THAT
THE STATE SANCTIONED SEVERAL
YEARS AGO THROUGH THE QUANTUM
FADE -- CATION SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE ON THIS MATTER THANK
YOU.
THING WAS GARCIA SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
THE CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE
TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLE AND TELL
ABOUT AYE SIXTY NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM.
TWENTY ONE FILE ITEM.
TWENTY TWO AB.
SIX FIVE SIX CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC SAFETY
MR GARCIA MAY GET OPEN.
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES A. B. SIX
FIFTY SIX HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED
FOR COORDINATED AN
INTERSECTIONAL STRATEGIES IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THE FACTORS
THAT CONTRIBUTE TO VIOLENCE.
AND THE ENVIRONMENTS IN WHICH IT
OCCURS.
CURRENT POLICIES AND PUBLIC
FUNDING RESPOND TO VIOLENCE IN A
REACTIONARY FASHION RATHER THAN
A PREVENTATIVE.
ONE COULDN'T OFFICE OF HEALTHY
AND SAFE COMMUNITIES WITH THE
GOAL OF SHOWCASING THE ALIGNMENT
BETWEEN VIOLENT BEHAVIOR AND
PUBLIC HEALTH INEQUITIES WILL
HELP TO REDUCE INCIDENTS OF
VIOLENCE IN THE STATE.
PLACE IN THIS OFFICE UNDER THE
PURVIEW OF THE SURGEON GENERAL
THAN VESTS AND COMMUNITY BASED
PREVENTION STRATEGIES WILL
FACILITATE THAT VISION BECOMING
A REALITY.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF
THE START OF THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OUT EYES FORTY
SEVEN THOSE.
ELEVEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THERE WAS WHAT A PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS TWENTY
THREE AND TWENTY FOUR BACK TO MR
GARCIA THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY
FIVE A. B..
TEN TEN ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TEN BY
SOME THE MENTOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA AND ACTUALLY TO
HOUSING.
MR GARCIA.
THANK YOU WAS SPEAKER AB TEN TEN
WOULD ALLOW DULY BECAUSE
CONSTITUTED GOVERNING BODIES OF
NATIVE AMERICAN RESERVATION OR
LUNCH IDEA TO BECOME ELIGIBLE.
APPLICANTS TO PARTICIPATE IN
SPECIFIED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROGRAMS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SPECTER YES FREE I
WILL.
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE [inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS OF WHO DESIRE VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TELEVOTE EYES
FIFTY NINE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM. TWENTY SEVEN WE'RE
ALSO PASSING TEMPORARILY ON THE
PREVIOUS ITEM FILE I'M.
TWENTY SIX THIS BRINGS US FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE AB.
THREE FIFTY TWO CORRECT.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
GREENHOUSE GASES MR GARCIA.
THINGS SPEAKER THIS BILL WILL
FURTHER REQUIRE AGENCIES TO
ALLOW AT LEAST THREE MONTHS
BETWEEN THE CALL FOR
APPLICATIONS IN THE DEADLINE.
AS IT RELATES TO THE JURY
FUNDING -- SOURCES -- TO REQUIRE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE REPORT
APPLICATIONS RECEIVED TO HELP
THE STATE UNDERSTAND WHERE THERE
ARE GAPS ARE BARRIERS TO
ACCESSING THESE IMPORTANT
RESOURCES.
MANY OF US HERE HAVE -- LOUDLY
STATED THAT -- ARE REGION'S NEED
TO SEE AN EQUITABLE APPLICATION
OF THESE FUNDS THIS BILL WILL
HELP US ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CSE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
IT IS OUR ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AREN'T OF A ALL MEMBER
SERVICE OUT OF A CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ICE FORTY
FIVE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE FILE ITEM THIRTY A. B.
SEVEN FIFTY THREE COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FIFTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND THAT KIND OF A KILLER AIR
POLLUTION MR GARCIA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
SEVEN FIFTY THREE WILL DIRECT
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
TO SET ASIDE 30%.
OF AB EIGHT ONE NINETEEN FUNDING
TO PAY FOR LOW CARBON FUEL
PRODUCTION.
SPECTER YES FREE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AGAIN MISS GARCIA SEEN
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE.
VOTERS ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
TAKES [inaudible]
FORTY ONE CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FORTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES
.
WHAT A PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEMS?
THIRTY ONE THREE THIRTY
SEVEN MEMBERS AS ALL WAVE TO THE
KIDS WHO JOINED US IN THE
GALLERY [inaudible]
YEAH
.
MEMBERS IF WE HAVE -- CHANGES.
VOTE CHANGES AT THIS TIME MISTER
KANSEN CHU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
WILL CHANGE ON FILE ITEM TWENTY
TWO SB.
SIX FIVE SIX FROM NO TO AYE.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KANSEN CHU ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
FIFTY SIX NOTE I'D
MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP.
FILE ITEM.
THIRTY THREE THIS IS H. R..
FORTY BY MS CARILLO.
CORY HOUSE RESOLUTION FORTY BY
SELLING MEMBER CARILLO RELATIVE
TO LATINA ACTION DAY
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THE RETENTION IS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'M SURE ALL MY LET THE
NOT THERE IN THE HOUSE BECAUSE
THIS IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
I AM PROUD TO PRESENT.
HR FORTY WHICH RECOGNIZES MAY
TWENTY THIRD JUST A FEW DAYS AGO
AS LATINA ACTION DAY.
AND ENCOURAGES THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO SUPPORT
THE CONTINUED WORKING COMMITMENT
OF ALL AT THE NOW LEADERS.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES GREAT FEMALE
LEADERS LIKE A LITTLE CHILL OUT
OF THE LOTUS WET THAT AN
ASSOCIATE JUSTICE OF THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT SONYA SO
THE MY YOUR WHO HAVE THE COURAGE
TO RISE UP DEFY THE NORMS AND
PRINT.
AND PROBABLY REPRESENT THEIR
LATINO COUNTERPARTS AND HAVE
INSPIRED LATINA ACTION DAY.
EVERY YEAR OVER FOUR HUNDRED
LETTING US FROM ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA CONVENE IN SACRAMENTO
FOR LATINO ACTION DAY.
AN ANNUAL PUBLIC POLICY ISSUES
CONFERENCE ORGANIZED BY THE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION IS FINE
US ORGANIZE FOR POLITICAL
EQUALITY HOPE. FOR THIRTY YEARS
THIS ONE DAY CONFERENCE HAS
CREATED AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
DIALOGUE BETWEEN CORPORATE
COMMUNITY AN ELECTED LET ME KNOW
OFFICIALS. TO DISCUSS CURRENT
ISSUES AND POLICIES AFFECTING
CALIFORNIA'S WOMEN OF COLOR.
THE CONFERENCE ALSO CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOUNG LATINO
LEADERS TO GAIN FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE OF ADVOCACY BY
ALLOWING THEM TO SPEAK TO
DIFFERENT REPRESENTATIVES AND
VOICE OUR CONCERNS.
ON ISSUES AFFECTING THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE WHO
OPENED UP THEIR OFFICE DOORS AND
MADE SURE.
THE LETTING US FROM ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA HAD ACCESS. TO
DISCUSS THE VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUES THAT THEY CARE ABOUT.
I TAKE PRIDE IN INCREASING THE
REPRESENTS -- REPRESENTATION OF
WOMEN AND THERE ARE SEVERAL
LATINA IN THIS BODY AND ACROSS
IN THE SENATE.
THAT ARE ON THE FRONT PAGE OF
ALLOW OPEN YOUR OWN IN LOS
ANGELES BECAUSE OF INCREASING
THE NUMBER OF LATINOS IN OUR
STATE LEGISLATURE SO THIS IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
AND AS WE CELEBRATE THE TWENTY
FIFTH ANNUAL AT BEING ACTION
THEY WHICH JUST TOOK PLACE A FEW
DAYS AGO.
IT IS THE PREMIER BOARDING TO
RECALL HOW FAR.
LATINOS HAVE COME AND HOW
INSPIRING IT IS TO SEE SO MANY
WOMEN REPRESENTED ACROSS OUR
STATE LEGISLATURE AND ESPECIALLY
LATINO WOMEN AS WE ARE THE
NUMBER ONE POPULATION THE
FASTEST GROWING POPULATION FOR
THE STATE.
OF CALIFORNIA SO WITH THAT
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE FOR H. R..
FORTY THANK YOU MISS KOREA.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE RESOLUTION BEFORE THE
BODY.
HIS CAREER WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE HR.
YES MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU.
MEMBERS OFFICIAL WE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON AGE. FORTY FOR THE
ROLE THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
HIS CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS THE CLERK
WILL.
CLOSER ALL THERE ARE SIXTY ONE
CO AUTHORS ADDED AND WE MAY TAKE
A VOICE VOTE ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED MEMBERS ARE PREPARED
TO LIFT THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM.
ELEVEN AB FIFTY SIX CLICK ON
POST.
ALL MEMBERS.
OF ALL MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS FOR THOSE WHO WISH
TO VOTE
.
MR GARCIA WHAT'S YOUR PLEASURE
SIR [inaudible]
THE WE GOT ABOUT AN HOUR.
MR GARCIA REPLACES THE CALL.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP. ONE OF MR CHOOSE ITEMS.
READING TAKE UP.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY SEVEN AB.
SIXTEEN ELEVEN THIS IS MISTER
DAVID CHIU THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVID CHIU AND
EXPLAIN TO HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
MR CHIU.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF AB SIXTEEN
ELEVEN WHICH WOULD AND SURPRISE
BILLING IN EMERGENCY ROOMS IN
CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE YOU
WOULD THINK THAT IF YOU NEED
EMERGENCY ROOM CARE YOU'D BE
COVERED.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY YOU'RE BROUGHT
TO THE WRONG HOSPITAL YOU COULD
BE SURPRISED BY AN EXORBITANT
BALANCE BILL THE BILL FOR THE
BALANCE BETWEEN WHAT A HOSPITAL
WANTS TO BE PAID AND WHAT
INSURANCE HAS PAID.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT COULD IMPACT SOME SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS AND WE ALL
KNOW THAT IF YOU'RE UNDERGOING A
LIFE THREATENING CONDITION YOU
DON'T HAVE THE WHERE WITH ALL.
TO DECIDE WHAT HOSPITAL TO GO.
TO THIS BILL WOULD PROTECT
PATIENTS IN ALL CIRCUMSTANCES
FROM SURPRISE BOUNCE BILLING
RELATED TO MERGE THE ROOM VISITS.
INSURED PATIENTS WOULD ONLY --
THEIR CO PAYMENT OR DEDUCTIBLE
TO RECOUP OTHER COSTS THE
HOSPITAL INSURANCE COMPANY WOULD
HAVE PROPOSED STANDARDIZED
NEGOTIATIONS SO THAT THERE IS
SOME PREDICTABILITY IN THE
PROCESS.
WE'VE TAKEN MANY AMENDMENTS
THROUGH SEVERAL COMMITTEES TO
BRIDGE THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
PATIENTS IN HOSPITALS ADDRESSING
MANY OF THE CONCERNS OF
HOSPITALS I'M COMMITTING THAT
WE'RE GONNA WORK CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS BILL IN THE SENATE.
WILL BE MAKING AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE AND THIS BILL WILL COME
BACK FOR A CONCURRENCE VOTE.
IN CLOSE AFTER A MEDICAL
EMERGENCY THE ONLY THING A
PATIENT SHOULD HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT IS HOW TO GET BETTER NOT
WHETHER A HOSPITAL BILL COULD%
LEAD TO FINANCIAL RUIN WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
HEY RICH JUNE.
DOCTOR WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
WE DEALT WITH THE ISSUE IN
GENERAL AROUND SURPRISE BILLING --
FOR FOR ALMOST EVERYTHING
RELATED TO MEDICAL CARE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN AND IT WAS
A REALLY DIFFICULT REALLY
DIFFICULT PROJECT.
AND IT WASN'T PERFECT AND ONE OF
THE THINGS WE DIDN'T ADDRESS WAS
EMERGENCY ROOMS.
AND IT'S CLEAR NOW THAT WE NEED
TO ADDRESS THAT.
I KNOW THAT NOBODY WANTS A
SURPRISE BILL YOU GOT YOU YOU
DON'T HAVE IT CERTAINLY AT TIMES
YOU DON'T HAVE CONTROL OF WHERE
YOU GO.
WITH RELATED TO AN EMERGENCY
MIGHT BE TAKEN THERE BY
AMBULANCE OR FAMILY MEMBER YOU
MIGHT BE OUT OF TOWN.
IT'S SIMPLY NOT FAIR THAT IF
YOU'RE NOT PART OF A NETWORK
THAT YOU GET PAID YOU GET THIS
EXORBITANT BILL AT THE END OF
THE DAY.
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S ANGST ABOUT
THE SECOND PART OF THE BILL
WHICH IS POTENTIALLY LOOKING AT
SETTING RATES -- FOR SOME OF THE
SERVICES AND I WOULD SAY THAT.
WE NEED TO LET THIS BILL MOVE
FORWARD AND WE NEED TO LOOK
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THAT PART OF
THE BILL I THINK THAT THERE AYE
THERE MAY BE VALID CONCERNS.
THIS GIVES ALL HOSPITALS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW WAS THE DATA
SHOW WAS THE REASONS SHOW US
WHAT YOU WHAT YOU MAY GAIN OR
WHAT YOU MAY LOSE FROM THIS BILL.
SO WE CAN ACTUALLY WORK WITH YOU
ON A SOLUTION EVERY TIME WE TRY
TO DO ANYTHING AROUND
AFFORDABILITY OR TRYING TO LEVEL
OUT COSTS.
IT'S THE END OF THE WORLD FOR
WHOEVER MIGHT BE AFFECTED.
SO.
WE NEED TO HAVE PEOPLE ACTUALLY
PROVE THE IT'S PRETTY SHOW IT
SHOWS THE INFORMATION GIVE US
THE OPPORTUNITY REACT JUST
SAYING THIS IS GONNA BE BAD FOR
US AND BAD FOR HOSPITALS.
IS NOT ACCEPTABLE LOT OF
PATIENTS ARE GETTING BILLS THAT
THEY SIMPLY DON'T DESERVE AND I
THINK THIS IS A THIS DEFICIT
BILLS A STEP FORWARD I WANT TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
ON THIS.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT WHEN IT
COMES BACK ON CONCURRENCE YOU
DON'T HAVE TO VOTE FOR IT.
BUT GIVE THIS GIVE THIS --
PROCESS AN OPPORTUNITY TO PLAY
OUT LET US PROTECT PATIENTS FROM
SURPRISE MEDICAL BILLS E. OURS
AND GIVE AND GIVE US A CHANCE TO
WORK THROUGH THIS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I'VE A THANK YOU DOCTOR
WOULD MEMBERS AS PLEASE KEEP THE
VOLUME LEVEL MANAGEABLE.
IN THE CHAMBER SO WE GET ALL
HERE THE DEBATE BEFORE THE BODY
IS POWER QUE AND YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB --
SIXTEEN ELEVEN AFTER THE PASSAGE
OF OUR COLLEAGUE FROM ALAMEDA IS
BILL THAT DEALT WITH BALANCE
BILLION HOSPITALS I ARRIVED IN
IN IN NETWORK HOSPITAL TO BE
TREATED BY AN ANESTHESIOLOGIST I
NEVER MATT WHO IS OUT OF NETWORK.
I RECEIVED A BILL THAT WAS WELL
BEYOND ANYTHING I EXPECTED THAT
I COULDN'T AFFORD.
AND I WAS SHOCKED I DIDN'T
REALIZE WHEN YOU SHOP IN NETWORK
HOSPITAL YOU CAN BE TREATED BY
AN OUT OF NETWORK COSTS DOCTOR
YOU'VE NEVER EVEN MATS.
AND THANKS TO THE BILL THAT THIS
BODY PASSED I WAS ABLE TO CALL
AND GET IT CORRECTED AND I ONLY
HAD TO PAY THE RATES THE MY
INSURANCE GUARANTEED.
AND SO I HAVE BENEFITTED FROM
THE WORK ON THIS SUBJECT THAT
THIS BODY HAS DONE AND SO I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE
THERE'S NO REASON THAT SOMEONE
WHO SHOWS UP IN THE EMERGENCY
ROOM.
AND EXPERIENCE IS THE SAME THING
I EXPERIENCE SHOULD HAVE TO PAY
AN EXORBITANT AMOUNT OF MONEY
JUST BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT THEY WERE GETTING.
AND I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE SECOND PART THE BILL I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO WORK ON
THE RATE SETTING PORTION AND I
TRUST HIM TO DO SO BUT I THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
THAT PROTECTS CALIFORNIANS SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE THAT.
MISTER MURATSUCHI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SIXTEEN ELEVEN YOUR COLLEAGUES I
THINK -- WHERE WE'RE SEEING IN
WASHINGTON THAT -- THERE IS
GROWING BY PARTISAN MOVEMENT TO
FIGHT BACK AGAINST SURPRISE
MEDICAL BILLS THIS IS PART OF
THAT EFFORT.
WHILE I I I TRUST MY MY SEAT
MADE WELCOME WILL CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE THE THE
ISSUES THAT REMAIN WE NEED TO
PUSH ON THE HOSPITAL INDUSTRY --
IN ORDER. TO TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE OF SURPRISE MEDICAL BILLS
IT'S IMPORTANT BILL TRANSFERS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THIS ITEM.
MR CHIU YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF THE
CHAMBER HEALTH COMMITTEE -- THE
PERSONAL STORY FORMER COLLEAGUE
BRENDA -- OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
TORRANCE.
I STARTED DIGGING IN THIS ISSUE
WHEN WE DISCOVERED IN OUR CITY
THERE WERE THOUSANDS OF PATIENTS
IN RECENT YEARS WITH AN
EMERGENCY BOUNCE BUILD EVEN
THOUGH.
THEY HAD INSURANCE IN EVERY ONE
OF OUR DISTRICTS IN EVERYONE OF
OUR DISTRICTS WE HAVE
INDIVIDUALS WHO UNFORTUNATELY
ARE EXPERIENCING THIS AGAIN
SEVEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS HAVE
INSURANCE BUT IF THEY GET SENT
TO THE WRONG EMERGENCY ROOM.
THEY CAN GET A BILL FOR TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN SOME
INSTANCES SEVERAL HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE HOSPITALS
AND OTHERS TO GET TO THE RIGHT
SOLUTION ON THIS THIS IS HARD
BUT WERE ASKING YOU TO DO TODAY
IS CAST A VOTE. FOR THOSE
PATIENTS WHO EITHER HAVE BEEN
BOUNCE BUILT OR COULD BE BALLOTS
BUILT. TO GIVE US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HOPEFULLY GET TO
THE RIGHT PLACE WE'RE ALMOST
THERE -- AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THEY MATURE WITHOUT THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS AT ABOUT.
THIS TAKES FORTY ONE VOTES
.
THIS IS CHIU MOVES A CALL.
MISTER CALDERON FOR PURPOSE THE
RISER.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE MOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SIX A. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIXTEEN TO THE AN ACTIVE FILE
[inaudible]
HELLO
MEMBERS WHILE WE WAIT I'D
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE STUDENTS
FROM.
WEST MARIN ELEMENTARY AND MR
LEVIN'S DISTRICT WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY
.
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOPER WE WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME STUDENTS FROM COYOTE
RIDGE ELEMENTARY AND HIS
DISTRICTS.
WHAT IMMEDIATE FAMILY
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE ARE BACK ON THE FILE.
WE ARE GOING TO BE TAKING A FILE
ITEM NUMBER. TWENTY FOUR THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER
.
TWENTY FOUR CORRECTION MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO LIFT THE CALL.
ON MISTER CHOOSE FILE ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN A. B. SIXTEEN
ELEVEN THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS FOR WHICH TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
AND TALLY THE VOTE.
AYE AYES FORTY FOUR DOES.
EIGHT THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND NOW MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY FOUR AB EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN
BY MISTER DAVID CHIU CLERK WILL
READ.
AT SOME LEVEL EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN
BY SOMETHING MEMBER DAVID CHIU
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC BANKS.
MR CHILL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF AB EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN AS WELL SO MANY
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH
MANY OF YOU THREE THREE
COMMITTEES AND MANY MOMENTS
ALONG THE WAY. FOR SOME I KNOW
THIS IS A NEW IDEA BUT IT'S
MODELED AFTER AN OLD IDEA AFTER
THE PUBLIC BANK OF NORTH DAKOTA.
WHICH ENJOY THAT'S ONE HUNDRED
YEAR ANNIVERSARY SUCCESS THIS
YEAR AS WELL AS PUBLIC BANKS AND
OTHER COUNTRIES.
OUR BILL DOES NOT ESTABLISH A
PUBLIC BANK IT SIMPLY CREATES A
PROCESS FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
CHARTER PUBLIC BANK A LONG MULTI
YEAR PROCESS WITH MANY
REGULATORY HURDLES.
ARE BILL REQUIRES A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BE OF A CERTAIN SIZE
BEFORE APPLYING FOR BANKING
CHARTER WE TOOK AMENDMENTS TO
EXCLUDE SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND
REQUIRES SMALLER COUNTIES. TO
FORM GPAS.
MAYBE YOU ASKED US QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW WE ENSURE THAT PUBLIC
BANK ASSETS ARE SAFEGUARDED
UNLIKE PRIVATE BANKS ARE BILL
REQUIRES A PUBLIC BANK TO ABIDE
BY A FIDUCIARY DUTY. TO PROTECT
ITS ASSETS REQUIRING COMPLIANCE
WITH ALL REQUIREMENTS OF
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS ON
BANKING LAW WITH ALL REPORTING
AND TRANSPARENCY REQUIREMENTS.
ARE BILL ALSO REQUIRES A PUBLIC
BANKS KEEP THE SAME COLLATERAL
QUORUM IT'S AS PRIVATE BANKS.
WE ESTABLISHED AMENDMENTS WE
ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS TO REQUIRE
PUBLIC BANK MAINTAIN FDIC
DEPOSIT INSURANCE AND TO CONDUCT
A FEASIBILITY STUDY AND HAVE A
FULLY BLOWN.
BUSINESS PLAN THAT ANALYZES
COSTS CAPITAL REQUIREMENTS
FINANCIAL PROJECTIONS IN THE
GALLERY WHEN APPLYING FOR A
BANKING CHARTER.
ALSO WANNA SAY WE ARE ENGAGED
VERY DEEPLY WAS STAKEHOLDER SUCH
AS CREDIT UNIONS AND OTHER
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS AND ARE
HOPEFUL THAT THESE CONVERSATIONS
WILL MAKE THE BILL EVEN BETTER
IN THE SENATE.
I WANT TO THANK THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THAT REMOVED
OUR BILL BECAUSE OF ALL THE
MEMBERS SO WE'VE TAKEN FROM ITS
JOB KILL A LIST.
AND OF COURSE I WANT TO THANK
THE ONE HUNDRED PLUS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE COME ON
IN SUPPORT OF A BILL.
AND A PARTICULAR WANT TO THANK
ALL OF OUR JOINT AUTHORS BUT BUT
MARK MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES WHO HAS BEEN A
TREMENDOUS PARTNER ON MOVING
THIS BILL AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MS WICKS YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND AND
COLLEAGUES I RISES A A PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF AB. EIGHT FIVE SEVEN
AB EIGHT FIVE SEVEN PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR LOCAL CITIES TO
ESTABLISH A PUBLIC BANK SHOULD
THEY CHOOSE AND SHOULD THEY GO
THROUGH.
THE NECESSARY AND CRITICAL
HURDLES TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
AYE ABILITY TO DO SO DOESN'T
REQUIRE THEM TO DO SO JUST GIVES
AN OPTION.
AND THE THING THAT I VERTICALLY
LIKE ABOUT THIS BILL IS THAT --
IT ALLOWS LOCAL INVESTMENTS BY
PUBLIC BANK THAT COULD INCLUDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CLEAN ENERGY
AND SMALL BUSINESSES.
IT GIVES THE POWER BACK TO THE
CONSUMERS THROUGH THIS PUBLIC
BANK AND UNLIKE PRIVATE BANKS
THAT PRIORITIZE SHAREHOLDER
RETURNS.
THESE PUBLIC BANKS COULD PROVIDE
BENEFITS TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN
THE RESIDENCE IN WHATEVER THOSE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES ONE AND I
THINK IT REALLY EMPOWERS THESE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
I WOULD STRONGLY URGE AN AYE
VOTE ON ON AB EIGHT FIVE SEVEN
APPRECIATE -- THE WORK -- OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM A LOS ANGELES
AND SAN FRANCISCO ON THIS.
MR MURATSUCHI YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I ARM.
HAVE HAD COUNT MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH MIGHT MY SEAT
MADE ABOUT THIS BILL AND I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT EVERYONE HERE UNDERSTANDS.
IT -- THE THE POTENTIAL ROAD
THAT WE'RE GOING DOWN HERE I I'M
I'M READING FROM THE LOS ANGELES
TIMES EDITORIAL -- THIS TALKING
ABOUT HOW.
THIS IS FROM MAY TWENTY SEVENTH
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO.
STATE LEGISLATURE CONSIDERS A
BILL TO LET.
EIGHT CITIES OPERATE BANKS STUDY
SO IT'S A REALLY BAD IDEA.
YOU KNOW I DISCORDANT FROM
PASSAGES OF OF THE OP ED.
FEASIBILITY STUDIES HAVE
REPEATEDLY FOUND THAT A PUBLIC
BANK WOULD BE TOO EXPENSIVE FOR
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND TOO
RISKY FOR TAXPAYERS WHILE ALSO
DELIVERING QUESTIONABLE VALUE
VALUE TO THE COMMUNITY.
COUNTLESS PUBLIC BANK PROPOSALS
HAVE BEEN ABANDONED OVER THE
YEARS BECAUSE BANKING IS REALLY
EXPENSIVE COMPLICATED IN RISKY
BUSINESS [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
I I THINK MOST OF US ALREADY
HAVE OUR MINDS MADE UP AS AS TO
HOW WE WANT TO VOTE ON THIS BUT
I JUST WANT TO SHARE.
YOU KNOW TO CAUTIONARY TALES.
IN A ONE I THINK IS IS IS
PROBABLY BETTER KNOWN IN ORANGE
COUNTY WHEN THEY WHEN THEY TRY.
TO RAISE FUNDS WITHOUT RAISING
TAXES THEY THEY STARTED ENGAGING
AND AND BOND TRADING.
AND THAT WILL LEAD TO THE ORANGE
COUNTY GOING TO BANKRUPTCY.
AND IN MY OWN DISTRICT IN THE
CITY OF GARDENA.
THEY THOUGHT IT WOULD BE A GREAT
IDEA.
TO FORM A MUNICIPAL INSURANCE.
COMPANY.
YOU KNOW THEY THOUGHT THAT THEY
CAN -- YOU KNOW.
CIRCUMVENT THE FOR PROFIT
MOTIVES OF OF INSURANCE OF
PRIVATE INSURANCE COMPANIES AND
TO PROVIDE THEIR COMMUNITY
SERVICE.
WELL IT ENDED UP BEING A HUGE
FINANCIAL DEBACLE.
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE
EXPERTISE.
YOU KNOW THE THE THE THE THE
MOTIVATIONS FOR PUBLIC ENTITIES
ARE ARE.
ARE -- YOU KNOW DIFFERENT FOR
BETTER OR WORSE -- AND IT GOT
THEM IN THE CITY BANK OF
GUARDINO ALSO ALMOST ENTERED
INTO BANKRUPTCY [inaudible]
AND SO.
YOU KNOW AS WE VOTE ON THIS BILL
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT --
YOU KNOW I I KNOW THAT THIS IS
TREMENDOUSLY POPULAR ESPECIALLY
WITH THE WITH THE OUR OUR OUR
PROGRESSIVE FRIENDS -- BUT WE WE
OPEN WE GO INTO THIS WITH OUR
EYES WIDE OPEN.
WE STUDY THE HISTORY WE LOOK AT
THE CAUTIONARY TALES -- I WE
MAKE OUR OUR VOTES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI MS
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I DO
WANT TO ECHO THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE SOUTH
BAY -- CONCEPTUALLY THIS.
IS A REALLY GOOD IDEA BUT I
THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT THAT
WE CONSIDER -- THE REALITIES
BEFORE US ACROSS -- THIS STATE --
AND I HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS BILL BECAUSE IT WILL
FOLLOW FDIC REGULATIONS THAT
MEANS THAT ALL OF THOSE IN THE
CANNABIS MARKETS WILL STILL BE
ON ABLE TO PARTICIPATE.
IN THESE BANKS IF YOU HAVE A
PUBLIC BANK DOES THAT MEAN THAT
YOU ARE ALSO WILL IT HAVE CITY
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE WORKING FOR
IT OR WILL IT JUST BE -- WILL
THOSE THAT ARE HIRED WILL BE
EMPLOYEES JUST BE FROM THE CITY
OR THERE'S JURISDICTION -- UNDER
WHICH THE BANK IS FOUNDED SO ARE
YOU INCREASING BUREAUCRACY OR
NOT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT HELPING
THE UNDER BANKED IN THE ON BANKS
BE ABLE TO OPEN AN ACCOUNT.
BUT THOSE -- POTENTIAL --
CLIENTS OF A BANK STILL HAVE TO
ABIDE BY THE CRITERIA SET BY
FEDERAL LAWS SO HOW WILL THESE
PUBLIC BANKS ENSURE THAT THOSE
FOLKS WHO ARE UNBANKED AND UNDER
BANKED GET CERTAIN KINDS OF
ACCOMMODATIONS. TO ALLOW THEM TO
BANK I WOULD BE REALLY CONCERNED
IF WE DID THIS AND YOU LOOKED UP
AND YOU SAW THAT THERE ARE ONLY
CITY BANKS IN CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THOSE COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE
IN SOUTH LA WHO PROBABLY
DESPERATELY NEED A COMMUNITY
BANK LIKE THIS WOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO HAVE ONE OPEN.
SO I THINK AS WE CONTINUE TO
TALK ABOUT THESE ISSUES WE AND
THEN ONCE AGAIN WHAT ABOUT THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR BANKS HOW
ARE THOSE FOLKS BEING SELECTED
WILL THOSE BE POLITICAL
SELECTIONS WILL THEY BE SELECTED
BY THE CITY MANAGER -- OR THE
MAYOR -- I THINK THESE ARE REAL
ISSUES THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO WORK OUT BEFORE WE GO DOWN
THIS ROAD SO I WOULD JUST ASK
FOR YOUR FOLKS TO REALLY
CONSIDER THOSE CONCERNS WHILE
PROCESSING HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
VOTE FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE
MINS GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU I ALSO RISE WITH THE A
LOT OF HESITATION FOR THIS
POLICY.
I HAVE A COMMUNITY THAT HAS A
LOT OF UNDER BANKED AND UNBANKED
CONSTITUENCY AND I GET THAT THE
STARS WANT TO HELP THEM OUT
THERE.
BUT I ALSO HAVE A COMMUNITY AT
THE SPEAKER THAT THE CORRIDOR
CORRUPTION.
AND HIM AND I SAID TOGETHER MOST
RECENTLY SOMEONE MY COUNCIL
MEMBERS RENDON USE WE'VE ALL
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THAT AGAIN.
AND IT'S BEEN THAT WAY SINCE
BEFORE I GOT HERE AND IT
CONTINUES.
OF TALK ABOUT HOW WHILE I'VE
BEEN FIGHTING AGAINST THAT FOR
THE LAST TEN YEARS I OFTEN FEEL
LIKE WE HAVE MOVED BACKWARDS
THAT AFFORD.
IN THAT SPACE AND SO WE'RE IS ME
TO GIVE ANOTHER TOOL TO MY
COUNCIL MEMBERS LOCAL LIKE IT'S
TO ABUSE.
ARE OUT THERE UNDER THE FALSE
PRETEXT OF HELPING A COMMUNITY
THAT REALLY IF THE NEED AND DOES
NEED SOME OF THE SERVICES OUT
THERE.
THAT'S WERE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION I KNOW IT'S POPULAR
WITH A LOT OF INDIVIDUALS OUT
THERE I HOPE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE WON'T ABILITIES AND WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND SOLUTIONS. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT JUST
GIVING ANOTHER TOOL FOR FOLKS TO
STEAL OUR MONEY AND MORE ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO A ROAD THE PUBLIC
TRUST OUT OF MY COMMUNITY THANK
YOU.
DOCTOR CHOI YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS SIDE RISE SO -- TO
OPPOSE SAW A AB -- EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE WHY
GOVERNMENT.
IS -- NOW TRYING TO AND FOR A
COMMERCIAL.
ALL MARKET PLAYS SO I THOUGHT
THAT WE HAD THE BODY OF A MAKING
POLICIES SO.
NOW WE CAN NOT ONCE WE START
THIS KIND OF A COMMERCIAL
ACTIVITIES OF FOR PROFIT.
WHY ARE YOU CAN MAKE IT TOUGH
FOR NON PROFIT BUT THE?
YOU CANNOT OPERATE -- SO TEN
NINETY TWO WITHOUT MAKING
PROFITS IN THE COMPETING WITH
THE ESTABLISH THE COME
COMMERCIAL ENTITIES.
AND THE NEXT TWO MAY BE --
HEALTH INSURANCE AND NEXT I'M IN
THE US ALREADY UP BEING PROPOSED
AS SOMEONE PAY UP IN A POLICY.
YOU KNOW WE CAN GO ON AND ON NOT
THIS KIND OF ACTIVITIES SO AND
THAT THIS IS SAW OF SUCH A BAD
IDEA.
AND THAT WE SHOULD NOT ALLOW
SUCH A RISK OF FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO EVEN STATE THAT TO
ENTER.
A SUCH A RISKY BUSINESS ARE AND
IN PRINCIPLE OR WE SHOULD NOT TO
COMPETE WITH THE IS TABLETS OF
COMMERCIAL ESTABLISHMENTS I
STRONGLY URGE YOU. TO TO VOTE NO.
THANK YOU DON'T CHOI MISTER
STONE YOUR RECORD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE IN ABSOLUTE SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL RECOGNIZE.
THEY COUNTIES PERFORM A LOT OF
THIS FUNCTION ANYWAY THEY TAKE
IN A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY
FROM LOCAL AGENCIES.
THEY HOLD ON TO THAT.
AND THAT MONEY SITS WITH THE
COUNTY.
WITHOUT BEING ABLE REALLY TO BE
USED TO THE BENEFIT OF OF THE
COMMUNITY.
THIS IS NOT A REPLACEMENT FOR
COMMERCIAL BANKS THIS IS NOT
EVEN NECESSARILY.
A WAY JUST YET FOR THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY TO GET BAGS WHAT IT IS
IS A WAY FOR THE MONEY THAT
CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE HOLDING
DUE TO THEIR NORMAL COURSE OF
BUSINESS. TO BE ABLE TO USE THAT
TO INVEST APPROPRIATELY IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
KEEP THAT CAPITAL LOCAL AND MAKE
IT WORK.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR A SOLUTION
FOR THE UNDER BANKS THIS IS A
VERY VIABLE POSSIBILITY IF
YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT.
THE ORANGE COUNTY AND SOME OF
THE OTHER TO BAKUL SAID IT
HAPPENED BEFORE REMEMBER THOSE
WERE HAPPENING WITH DECISION
MAKERS.
OPERATING WITHOUT A LOT OF
STRUCTURE AROUND THEM FOR ANY
REAL OVERSIGHT.
THIS PROVIDES A PATH FOR THAT
OVERSIGHT PROVIDES A PATH FOR
THE MONIES THAT ARE BEING HELD
ANYWAY.
SOMETIMES HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ACROSS THE STATE WELL
ACROSS THE CALIFORNIA MUCH MORE
THAN THAT BUT IN A GIVEN COUNTY.
POTENTIALLY HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO VERY
CAUTIOUSLY BE WORKED INTO THE
COMMUNITY TO THE BENEFIT OF THAT
COMMUNITY.
AND FOR ALL THIS IS A VERY
VIABLE HAVE.
UNDER A STRICT STRUCTURE THAT IS
NOT REPLACING LOCAL BANKS IT IS
NOT REPLACE IN THE COMMERCIAL
SECTOR IT FEELS A VERY DIFFERENT
NASH AND IT WILL BE A VERY GOOD
A GOOD.
USE OF THE MONEY THAT IS
COLLECTED ACROSS CALIFORNIA FOR
LOCAL REINVESTMENT AND I URGE
AND EITHER.
THEY WERE STONE DR QUIRK YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
FIRST OF ALL I I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. EIGHT FIVE
SEVEN REGRETFULLY.
I HAVE TREMENDOUS RESPECT FOR
THE AUTHOR BUT I JUST DON'T
THINK THIS IS A GOOD IDEA
[inaudible]
ARM.
WE ALL REMEMBER -- EIGHT OH NINE
WHEN.
THIS OP WHEN BANKS -- SUPPOSEDLY
WELL MANAGED WENT OUT OF
BUSINESS WERE ABSORBED BY OTHER
BANKS.
OF REMEMBER THE SAVINGS AND
LOANS TO BAKUL.
EVEN A WELL RUN.
BANK IN THE WRONG SITUATION.
OUR AND IF YOU PARTICULAR IF YOU
INVEST PROJECT PREDOMINANTLY
LOCALLY YOU'RE MORE LIKELY TO
GET CAUGHT UP.
AT THE SAME TIME THAT YOUR TAXES
ARE GOING DOWN -- YOUR LOCAL
ECONOMY IS GOING DOWN AND IF YOU
INVESTED PRIMARILY THERE IT'S
JUST TAKING A RISK THAT'S TOO
MUCH.
NOW IN MY OWN CITY WHILE I WAS
ON CITY COUNCIL WE HAD A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
ARE IN.
THAT WAS NOT IN RESERVE BUT
SIMPLY THAT WE HAD TO KEEP.
AND THAT WAS INVESTED VERY
CONSERVATIVELY IN THE STATE WIDE
FUND THAT THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES HAVE AVAILABLE TO THEM.
BUT IT'S INVESTED IN.
TREASURY BILLS OTHER THINGS THAT
ARE EXTREMELY EXTREMELY -- SAFE.
AND THAT'S WHERE YOUR MONEY
SHOULD BE.
NOW IF YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT --
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE INVESTING
IN A WALL STREET BANKER YOU'RE
SENDING YOUR MONEY TO WALL
STREET BANKS.
THERE ARE ALTERNATIVES FOR THE
CREDIT UNIONS I DON'T KNOW THAT
THEY ARE FOR ALL THE SERVICES.
THAT MISTER CHIU WOULD LIKE BUT
THEY CERTAINLY.
DO WORK WITH THE COMMUNITY --
THEY'RE NOT -- MOTIVATED BY THE
OUR PROFIT MOTIVE AND THEY HAVE
BEEN EXTREMELY SAFE.
STABLE AND I WOULD JUST URGE THE
OFFER AUTHORED TO THINK ABOUT
WORKING WITH THE CREDIT UNIONS
WHICH ARE ALREADY WELL
ESTABLISHED HAVE A VERY LONG
HISTORY OF STABILITY.
AND SEE WHAT CAN BE DONE THERE
AND WORK WITH THAT INDUSTRY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT QUIRK.
MR SANTIAGO.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AND I I APPRECIATE THE
RIGORS DEBATE.
AND LIKE ALL NEW IDEAS SOMETIMES
ARE CHALLENGING.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT THE
BILL REALLY DOES AND MOST OF YOU
HAVE HEARD FOR ME.
A NUMBER OF TIMES THE BILL DOES
NOT ESTABLISH BANKS
AUTOMATICALLY.
IT DOESN'T A PUTS A VERY
RIGOROUS PROCESS.
A RICH A VERY RIGOROUS PROCESS
THAT REQUIRES A FEASIBILITY
STUDY.
SO IF YOU CAN'T PASS A
FEASIBILITY STUDY.
YOU CAN'T EVEN MOVE FORWARD.
YOU'VE GOT A YOU'VE GOT TO
DECLARE A PUBLIC GOOD.
AND WHY NOT WHY NOT A BANK THAT
WORKS FOR PUBLIC GOOD AND LOCAL
AREAS AND REINVEST ARE DOLLARS
THAT IS MOTIVATED BY DOING GOOD.
RATHER THAN MOTIVATED BY THE
BOTTOM LINE.
THEN YOU STILL GOT TO FOLLOW ALL
FEDERAL LAWS.
ALL FEDERAL LAW IS GONNA BE
FOLLOWED.
YOU'VE GOT TO GO TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT OFFICE.
OOPS I STUMBLE THEIR BUT YOU'VE
GOT TO GO THROUGH THAT THAT'S
NOT A THAT'S NOT A NEARLY
PROCESS THAT YOU GO THROUGH THAT
IS A SERIOUS PROCESS.
SO A LOT OF THE CONCERNS OF
FOLKS THAT SAID I APPRECIATE.
BUT YOU WON'T BE ABLE TO GO
THROUGH THAT PROCESS.
IF YOU HAD SOME OF THOSE
PROBLEMS THAT HAVE BEEN THAT
HAVE BEEN SUGGESTED ON THE FLOOR.
BUT I APPRECIATE THE DEBATE ON
THE LAST.
YOU HAVE TO BE FDIC INSURED.
WE'RE NOT SAYING JUST GO PUT
MONIES AT RISK YOU HAVE TO BE
FDIC INSURED.
AND SOMEONE MENTIONED -- THE LA
TIMES ARTICLE.
BUT WE APPRECIATE THE RIGOROUS
DEBATE.
WE DIDN'T HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REAP BOTTLE BECAUSE WE WERE
NEVER CONTACTED.
LET'S BE VERY CLEAR THE REPORT
THAT THEY POINT TO WAS ABOUT
CANNABIS DOLLAR WAS NOT ABOUT
THE TYPE OF DOLLARS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
AND AT THE VERY LEAST AT THE
VERY LEAST I WOULD SAY.
THAT I DON'T THINK REASONABLY.
IT IT'S A IT'S A CHALLENGING
IDEA TO THINK.
THAT WE SHOULD PUSH BIG BANKS TO
DO A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAT
WE SHOULDN'T THINK ABOUT DOING A
NEW WAY OF BANKING BECAUSE THE
OLD WAY OF BANKING ISN'T
NECESSARILY WORKING FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES.
WE HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM WITH
INCOME INEQUALITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE GOT THE CHALLENGE.
BILLIONAIRES AND WALL STREET TO
DO SOMETHING A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY.
AND LOOK WE'VE GOT A LONG DEBATE
IN THE SENATE.
HOW MANY IDEAS HAVE WE PUSH
THROUGH THIS THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATURE THAT ARE NOT BEEN
PERFECT?
BUT ARE ON THEIR WAY TOWARDS
IMPROVING EIGHT AT TOWARDS
IMPROVING.
THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR PEOPLE.
THIS LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WILL
ALLOW US. TO ADDRESS CONCERNS.
WILL ALLOW US TO ADDRESS THOSE
COMMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE.
AND GET TO A FINAL PRODUCT.
THAT WILL IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIVEAU.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM.
MR CHIU YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE RIGOROUS DEBATE -- THIS IS A
DEBATE THAT WE'VE BEEN HAVING
ALL YEAR -- AND I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT AND THANK THE BANKING
COMMITTEE THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FOR PUTTING US AS A
SUPPORTERS THIS BILL THROUGH THE
PACES TO ADDRESS.
THOSE QUESTIONS.
I WOULD SUBMIT THAT WE HAVE DONE
THAT AND LET ME JUST TAKE A FEW
OF THE ISSUES THAT AND REYES
FIRST OF ALL WITH REGARDS TO THE
POSSIBILITY THE POLITICIZATION
OF BANKS.
UNLIKE PRIVATE BANKS.
WHERE THERE IS NO IF I DO SURE
DUE TO THE PUBLIC WE ESTABLISH
THAT WITH THIS?
THERE'D BEEN QUESTIONS AROUND
THE IMPACT OF THIS BILL ON
SMALLER FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS.
SINCE I GRADUATED FROM SCHOOL
SOME TWENTY PLUS YEARS AGO.
THE LARGEST WALL STREET BANKS
HAVE SWALLOWED UP 75% OF
CALIFORNIANS LOCAL BANKS.
AND THIS BILL.
THIS BILL ENVISIONS A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN ANY LOCAL
PUBLIC BANK.
AND CREDIT UNIONS AND LOCAL
COMMUNITY BANKS JUST AS IS THE
MODEL WITH THE BANK OF NORTH
DAKOTA WHICH HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
THE FOR THE BETTER PART OF A
CENTURY.
I WE'VE CERTAINLY HEARD THE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THERE MAY BE SOME LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT EITHER DON'T
HAVE THE WHERE WITH ALL TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THIS OR FOR
HOME.
THEY MAY NOT HAVE THE FINANCIAL
LEADERSHIP TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS
WE ARE AT THIS MOMENT DISCUSSING
AMENDMENTS THAT WE WOULD ACCEPT
IN THE SENATE TO ADDRESS.
THOSE VERY CONCERNS.
BUT LET ME JUST CLOSE BY SAYING
WE NEED ANOTHER OPTION THAN WHAT
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW I THINK
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT AT THE
MOMENT WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
OF ASSETS BEING HELD BY OUR
CITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE ESTIMATE IS SEVEN
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT IS GOING TO THE LARGEST
WALL STREET BANKS IN THE COUNTRY.
AND THOSE BANKS ARE INVESTING
PUBLIC MONIES.
AGAINST OUR CALIFORNIA VALUES IN
FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRIES IN GUN
MANUFACTURERS IN PRIZE PRIVATE
PRISONS IN COMPANIES WITH UNFAIR
LABOR PRACTICES.
AND WE KNOW.
THAT THESE LARGEST BANKS HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF CONSUMERS WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING PREDATORY LENDING
WHO HAD MILLIONS OF FAKE BANK
ACCOUNTS OPEN IN THEIR NAMES.
WHO'VE LOST HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OF INTEREST PAYMENTS
AFTER THE GREAT RECESSION.
WE ALL HAVE LITERALLY MILLIONS
OF HOMEOWNERS WHO'VE BEEN
VICTIMIZED BY THE MORTGAGE
FORECLOSURE CRISIS STUDENTS
VICTIMIZED BY GREENLANDERS SMALL
BUSINESSES TONIGHT ACCESS TO
CAPITAL.
THIS IS A BILL TO SUGGEST
ANOTHER PATH IT WOULD ALLOW FOR
THE POSSIBILITY OF CHARTERING A
LOCAL BANK BUT WE ALL KNOW WHAT
THE CRITIQUE OF THIS BILL IS.
THE REQUIREMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PLACED ALREADY BY THIS ASSEMBLY
IN THIS BILL.
COULD LIKELY MAKE IT SO
DIFFICULT THAT WOULD BE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR ANY LOCAL
JURISDICTION TO CREATE A LOCAL
BANK BECAUSE WE HAVE ESTABLISHED
ALL OF THESE CRITERIAS BUT WHAT
WE'RE SAYING TO COLLEAGUES IS.
LET'S GIVE US A CHANCE TO HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION GIVE US A
CHANCE TO DO THIS AND WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
OUR CLUB IN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THESE ARE VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE VOTE
WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE VOTE.
I SWEAR WHEN THOSE.
TWENTY SIX THE MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
MEMBERS I'M.
TO LIFT THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN A. B.
FIFTY SIX THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
WELL.
CLOSER ALL.
AND TELL YOU TO VOTE.
ICE FORTY ONE KNOWS.
NINETEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS AFTER THESE HEAVY
DEADLINE WEEKS WE LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE OUTSTANDING WORK
OF ARE CHEAPER ACOSTA WILSON IS
OUTSTANDING STAFF.
THAT HAVE KEPT US IN.
THE RUN AROUND THE CLOCK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
I BELIEVE WE ARE DONE FOR THE
DAY.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS THE
WARRIORS TIP OFF TONIGHT AT SIX
PM.
FRIDAY MAY THIRTY FIRST NO FLOOR
SESSION NO CHECK IN SESSION
MONDAY JUNE THIRD FLOOR SESSION
IS AT ONE PM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING OVER
THE PAST RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING A FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY WHAT
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER GIBSON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS AT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
JUNE THIRD ONE PM IN THE FORM
CALLS LIFTED